well you let these diverse people be
free so that they can think up ideas
that might be appropriate for the next
problem and then you let them talk which
is why free speech is so important it's
like without that we do not have a
problem-solving mechanism we can't
capitalize this is biological diversity
this is the manner in which organisms
themselves have adapted to the entire
structure of reality you don't mess with
that you certainly don't do it
politically and you need free speech you
know and it's part of part of that is
also opponent processing you know if i
want to move my hand as smoothly as
possible this way
i put this hand up to stop it and push
and then i can do it and a lot of the
processes that occur biologically are
like that opponent processes they make
for precision and control and a lot of
our political structures in in the west
because we allow for free discussion our
opponent process
their opponent processes and so we have
a problem we get a diverse range of
opinions god only knows which is right
and then we can talk them through then
maybe we don't implement something you
know catastrophically stupid
and so
i i i think the other point to extract
from what you said is it's diversity
it's also the decentralization principle
yeah yeah right exactly this is a key
key elements of conservatism is this
first of all a sense of humility uh
conservatism is about a sense of
humility a sense of humility about what
you can really know
and what you can control
and uh
in my experience dealing with my
colleagues democrats they have no they
have no such humility they do believe
that they can solve every problem and
sometimes i think that's well
intentioned and sometimes it's not i
think it's just important to kind of
extract
you know what what they want but then
but then let us figure out how to get
there
[Music]
hello everybody i'm very pleased today
to have with me congressman dan crenshaw
dan and i have talked before
but but here we are talking again
originally from the houston area dan
crenshaw is a proud sixth generation
texan from an early age he knew that he
wanted to serve his country with the
most elite fighting force in history the
u.s navy seals
his father's career in the texas oil and
gas industry moved his family all over
the world including ecuador and colombia
where he attended high school as a
result dan is fluent in spanish
in 06 dan graduated from tufts
university where he earned his naval
officer commission through navy rotc
following graduation he immediately
reported to seal training
had something very difficult to do by
the way in coronado california where he
met his future wife tara after
graduating sealed training he deployed
to fallujah iraq to join seal team three
his first of five deployments overseas
on his third deployment in 2012
after six months of combat operations he
was hit by an improvised explosive
device blast during a mission helmlin
so in helmand province afghanistan he
was evacuated and awoke from a medically
induced coma learning that his right eye
had been destroyed in the blast and that
his left eye was badly damaged he was
medically retired in september of 16 as
a lieutenant commander lieutenant
commander in the u.s after serving 10
years in the sealed teams he left with
two bronze stars one with valor the
purple heart and the navy commendation
medal with veler among others soon after
he completed his masters in public
administration at the harvard kennedy
school of government
in november of 18 dan was elected to
serve the people of texas second
congressional district in congress he
serves on the house energy and commerce
committee which has the broadest
jurisdiction of any legislative
committee in congress he also serves on
the house select committee on climate
crisis among others
thank you
very much for agreeing to talk to me
today
well thank you for having me it's an
honor uh as i've noted many times one of
our intellectuals appreciate i
appreciate it something
yeah well that's really something to uh
to hear from someone like you i can tell
you that so
we just had an election in canada and
one of the things that wasn't discussed
was what happened in afghanistan because
canadians served there as well and i've
been putting together this idea that i'd
like to put four or five people who
served there together on a podcast and
get a grounds eye view of the situation
and but i've got you right now and
so
what in the world were we doing there
and
what happened and
was it any use and
what's your opinion about that
because i just don't know you know so
anything you can tell me would be real
helpful
yeah um
it's a complicated one but at the same
time it's not that complicated you know
why let's start with some of the first
questions i mean
why do we go in there in the first place
um
i went there in the first place because
of 9 11 and the united states invoked
article 5 of the nato treaty which is
how canada gets involved
because you're our friends and if we get
attacked we ask you to come help you say
sure and
americans have a long history of working
with canadians special operations and uh
you know actually where i was stationed
in kandahar
at least for a while that was a purely
canadian base that's why there was a
hockey rink
for instance
and uh and so you know long-time
partners but why we were there well
because of 9 11. and we decided that
and i think rightfully decided
that uh there needed to be a response to
the attacks on 911 because they
originated from al qaeda and al qaeda
was being harbored by the taliban in
afghanistan and so we decided that the
taliban no longer should be in control
of afghanistan that was day one and
basically everybody agreed with what we
should do on day one now day two and i'm
speaking in kind of general terms but
let's call it day two
um
the question becomes now that we kick
some butt do we leave um
and this was always a difficult question
and this kind of gets to the rest of the
questions as far as what we're doing
there
why and this is there's a question
people have been wrestling with for 20
years
and there's been disputes about it and
it's it's it's not exactly a simple
question or a simple answer because your
alternatives are basically
come away with the win you know call it
a win
i don't know if it's a win but it's
certainly retribution uh call it revenge
but
the next question is okay do we have an
interest in prevention do we have an
interest in future prevention of future
attacks and that's uh
that and the answer to that question
became yes we do which is why the global
war on terror uh became the buzzword for
20 years
and
um
the difficult question was always do we
let afghanistan just fall back into the
hands of the taliban
or do we stay
and try to at least create some
semblance of a government that will be
our partner
uh that we can align with and that we
can conduct counter terror operations
with and prevent another another 911.
and that became the choice for 20 years
and that's what we chose to do and um we
can argue and people like to sort of
take easy swipes at that um and say well
look they they were never really
prepared we were just it seemed like an
endless war we're just you sort of
institutionalized the war we're just
doing the same things over and over
again
but they forget what the alternative is
and life is always about assessing what
the alternatives are it's easy to it's
easy to be
disenchanted with the present or the
current choice it's a little bit harder
to actually think about it and assess
what the alternative is and it turns out
there isn't really good alternatives in
a situation like this so you can stay at
war
um or you can
say that you ended it
and refused to acknowledge that there's
actually an entire ideology out there
that has no interest in ending that war
with you
you know and what i tell people is
and you can kind of get what side of the
debate i'm on um
you know call it an endless war call it
what you want the fact is is you send
guys like me over there as an insurance
policy that's so that there's no more
911s and you know what did we get for 20
years of war in afghanistan well we got
no more 911s and that's certainly not
nothing
uh it's actually pretty significant
and do you think that's a reasonable
causal link
i mean you did get us
or we did i suppose is another way of
looking at it not that i'm taking any
credit for that but
so that did happen and and as you said
there hasn't been another major attack
and the incidence of terrorism worldwide
or that sort of terrorism does seem to
have declined it's always a trick to
attribute the cause of that correctly
so
it's it's hard i mean it's but
al qaeda
kaida is an organization that exists
primarily to externalize their
operations
meaning they exist to attack
homeland whether that's europe or the us
or canada
isis for instance is an organization
that exists to build an islamic
caliphate now they're all kind of under
the same umbrella i mean and the taliban
isis al-qaeda to the extent that they
fight with each other it's mostly about
power structures as opposed to you know
ideological differences they're all on
the same team there they just might have
different strategies um and so we
decimated al qaeda and al qaeda tried to
move to iraq i'll try to cut tried to
move to yemen and we just go after them
now what that does is is it an endless
war yes because these people are in an
endless war with us you know we weren't
at war on september 10th 2001.
we weren't at war in the year 2000 when
the uss cole was hit we weren't at war
when our embassies in tanzania and kenya
were hit in 1997 and we weren't at war
in 1993 when the world trade center was
bombed but somebody was at war with us
and this is what i have to remind people
and we can say we ended a war a couple
months ago but we didn't end any war
and the intel suggests that al qaeda is
rapidly reforming and
and is now now they have the space and
the time because somebody like me is not
going after them anymore
and that that's the key ingredient there
are they on the run or are they or are
they kicked back and and planning the
next the next big operation the next
really really glamorous operation the
really dramatic attack that they like to
do you know that's better than just a
underwear bomber going on an airplane um
and so do you think they have that they
have that space now in afghanistan and
so i got to tell you a brief story there
was a canadian federal election just not
too long ago and maybe a month before
that or so one of the cabinet members of
our prime minister's government he was
re-elected with the minority government
justin trudeau she referred to the
taliban the new government in in
afghanistan
under the taliban as our brothers
and uh you know that wasn't so different
in some sense from some of the missives
that have been coming from the u.s state
department but many people weren't too
thrilled with that description and you
know the feeling of more hard-headed
people and maybe they're wrong is that
you know it's the same old characters
now that have obtained power and we
better watch the hell out and so is that
over suspicious should they be offered
an olive branch it's like what's your
sense about the right way forward with
that new government
well i i don't think it's overly
suspicious at all these are certainly
the same people
that took my eye these are the same
people now granted i get to wear cool
eye patch as a result of it so you know
i'm not complaining too much yeah you do
look good you don't look cool
it's not there's no doubt about that i
read a comedian's comment about you uh
uh i think he apologized for it was
something like uh it looked like what
was it a private eye and a porno flick
or something like that which is a good
joke
but
it made it important that was that yeah
that part was the good joke that was
that part was the good joke it actually
was pretty funny uh that that kind of
sparks the history of my
or the birth of my political career i
guess we could talk about that
yeah yeah
well let's finish off with the taliban
and then let's get that finished so
taliban
yeah taliban are terrible um and they
haven't changed one bit if anything
they're emboldened and ruthless like the
haqqani network again a ruthless
ruthless terrorist organization and drug
writing operation you know the head of
that i think is the uh the second in
command for taliban right now
um the the people in charge you know
there's there's groups that we have
intel they're groups in charge of
security around uh the kabul airport the
taliban groups uh were
suicide bombing experts i mean these
people all come they're all cut from the
same cloth nothing has changed uh we're
seeing plenty of videos of them hanging
people murdering people executing people
rounding up women selling them off uh
you know what women are under attack in
afghanistan in a very serious way so
unfortunately yeah and yet the state
department is calling on them to be
diverse inclusive and equitable and uh
it's it's
something nasty about that
i think you did i think it's just it's
like i mean i'm not opposed to working
with
you know questionable characters around
the world i mean i come from the special
operations community i also come from
the intelligence community this is this
is what you have to do sometimes
um but this isn't necessarily one of
those cases this was this was the time
to put your foot down and refuse to let
this happen
now when you let it happen and the
question is what do you do after the
fact because we're not going to go back
in and invade
so you do have to work with them to an
extent and it was the sort of deal with
the devil
and i do understand that but but you
don't have to speak so
favorably about them either i mean come
on i mean there's there's there's at
least some
there's at least some dignity that we
might preserve i would hope um but our
state well you also maybe might not
you might also not say things that would
lead them to overtly mock you
like yeah diversity inclusivity and
equity missives that's a bit it'll need
let's call it naive side to say the
absolute least
yeah
it's it's how locism has infected uh
serious people i mean
to say the least it's
it's it's infuriating and it's it's it's
caused um you know quite a bit quite a
bit of angst in the united states uh
people on both sides of the debate in
both sides of the aisle are deeply
unhappy about it and we feel deeply
embarrassed and as we should especially
because it was so preventable um one of
the key takeaways from the hearings this
week where general milley is the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
and the secretary of defense were
testifying before the senate in the
house in front of the armed services
committees i'm not on those committees i
didn't get to and get to ask them
questions but
but one thing that really came out and
that i hoped would come out was
you know our our defense department told
them very clearly you need to leave at
least a few thousand troops there
um
there's a very it's almost guaranteed
that if we go down to zero because you
know slogans all right this is this is
where i get very upset with the debate
about all this because i feel like the
the push to remove troops
is effectively based on a slogan an
emotional slogan
maybe two you know what slogan means the
derivation of that word it's very
interesting
it's from slough
garum it's welsh slough garam it means
battle cry of the dead
well that's interesting and it yeah yeah
perfectly
and it fits perfectly with how i'm using
the word slogan now because it
i think it caused these i think these
emotional slogans
were effectively political battle cries
that caused death and um when you say
you know this emotional cries to bring
the troops home as if i need your help
right as if i as if i am not a a smart
individual that volunteered to go and
and
defend america as if i need somebody's
sympathy i don't
uh in the other slogan no more endless
wars you know and
it just it just it just reduces a very
complex and important topic into a
very foolish debate and i think that's
how we ended up in this place where
where the number had to be zero it
couldn't be 2 500 it couldn't be 5 000
couldn't couldn't be something
reasonable right because i'm not saying
we have a hundred thousand troops there
like when i was deployed in afghanistan
it might have been 120 000 troops there
and you know maybe as a surge it's
debatable whether that's necessary or
not but but it's certainly not
sustainable forever and and i think what
people became unable to do is
distinguish between this enormous
resources being expended on nation
building let's call it i think that
again i think that's an overly
simplistic term but they don't like
hundreds of thousands of troops there
indefinitely fair enough i mean
why would you i totally get that i don't
think we should do it either and i also
don't think that we should be trying to
export democracy but that's but that's
been of a bit of a straw man argument or
a red herring really
obviously related terms but
it's you know this whole idea that we're
trying to export democracy that was
never the point
you know and it's it's an unfair
criticism of the bush administration
they their goal was not to export
democracy now you might make a different
argument on iraq
i think they got over their skis on that
one but let's set that debate aside well
in afghanistan it was never the point
it was just that on day two like i said
you have a question do you try to build
some semblance of a government that you
can work with or do you just let the
taliban take it over and then and you're
right back to where you were right
before september 11 2001.
and what have you gained um so what do
you think would have happened if you
would left five or ten thousand troops
there
uh we'd be in a very good situation
right now the afghan government would
still be
up and uh up and running and there'd be
little skirmishes uh little combat
operations
for a while there just would yeah and
why do you think that that that small
number of troops sorry we have a bit of
a lag so i'm being a bit rude here but
why are you convinced that uh
a number five thousand ten thousand
something like that why are you
convinced that that would have been
sufficient
well because
it's sufficient enough to hold certain
airfields um commit certain air power to
our afghan partners and honestly give
them the morale boost that they need to
go fight it on their own um it also
provides logistical support to them i
mean a true truly modern army is you
know five percent combat 95 logistics
that's what makes the american military
so unbelievable is that we can deploy
anywhere in the world and our logistics
are second to none
and um you know that's something that's
not not quite realized and we're also
it's not all the experience
i watched an extensive series on world
war ii that concentrated and it was
narrated by eisenhower it was it
concentrated a lot on logistics which i
found absolutely fascinating and it
stunned me as well just the sheer
difficulty of supplying tanks and men
with gasoline once the english channel
was crossed that was amazing operation
they built these huge spools out of with
as much steel in them as battleships and
unrolled pipelines across the english
channel it's like and that was like one
amazing got someone absolutely beyond
comprehension that it and and that it
was possible and that it worked so the
logistics this the supply of the army
all of that that's that is really
something and people don't know how
complex that is so so you figure five to
ten thousand
and and that was killed by slogans
it was killed by slogans it was killed
by emotional slogans um because i mean
like you can't overstate the importance
of logistics and if you ex you know and
people say well we've been there for 20
years i mean why can't they handle it
i mean you you handle it being a new
country after 20 years that's not
exactly a a long standing long a long
time you know
it's it's difficult um you know give
these guys some slack i mean they've
been trying to build a plane while it's
falling through the air
uh for years and it's not easy and um
and you've got an insurgency that's
ruthless and doesn't play by the same
rules now they've got ieds set up
everywhere you know this this stuff is
hard and it takes time
you got to remind people we were in
south korea
since the 50s
they didn't have an election until the
80s
you know it takes a while
and would anybody say at this point that
it wasn't worth it that we should have
just left and and let that fall to
communist china control the way north
korea is i don't think so
i mean south korea south korea is quite
a place man yeah absolutely
look at it thrive away man
hooray and
and that would have never
happened without our presence there just
never and it's not like they ever stop
the war either they're technically still
at war so i just i just think they are
now now look are we losing americans
there no
but uh we also haven't lost an american
in afghanistan for a year and a half
until these marines were killed um
just a few weeks ago so
you know and before that and people are
like well that's because of the treaty
with the taliban it possibly possibly
got you know they have time on their
hands they're they're strategic thinkers
but before that when we didn't have a
treaty we had an average of six to seven
deaths in afghanistan every year i'll
tell you what the us military loses a
hell of a lot more than that suicide and
random accidents
um so you know it wasn't i wouldn't call
this a war in the traditional sense it
was not like what i was dealing with and
even what i was dealing with in 2012 was
certainly not like 2010.
uh it was you know it's war is relative
um and uh i don't see what was going on
since about 2014 as a full-blown war by
any stretch it's a
so let me summarize what you said and
see if i got it right so you think that
20 years of involvement kept
terrorism at bay pretty effectively and
now that's done with and
whatever was there before is
is mounting again and has been
emboldened that was your word and
emboldened by what exactly well by the
fact that they took over the government
of afghanistan instantly and and are
back in control and then i have some
parallel questions along with that if i
got that right
um
what is this
endless war that we're in apparently
about and who's underneath it because i
have been watching american foreign
policy for a long time and i keep
wondering about pakistan and i keep
wondering about saudi arabia which has
all this immense wealth and has the
proclivity to fund rather radical ideas
all around the world continually
and so
i know those are terrible things to ask
you about
or even to talk about but
well and i'm not like
an expert on this but but i know enough
um you know what we're dealing with is
is islamic extremism that
really originated from saudi arabia
the madrasas of saudi arabia and wahhabi
islam um which is a very extreme form of
islam and that materialized over time
and
i think what's interesting is and i'm
going to get the year wrong and the
exact attack run there was a major
islamic extremist attack in saudi arabia
decades ago and ever since that moment
the saudi arabian government sort of had
this deal with the devil with them leave
us the hell alone
and we'll we'll at least harbor you
right so that's why people kind of look
to saudi arabia as this culprit even
though at a governmental level they're
an ally and again it deals with the
devil yeah because it's like strange
it's in its you know why are we allies
with saudi arabia well because they're
because they're the only uh
geostrategic deterrents to iran and
they're worse
this is life you know this is this is
this is realism um
as opposed to who we wish people were
um but that that's sort of where it came
from and this has been around for a
while and they hate us because they hate
us
you know and westerners are always
looking for this sort of this this
logical reasoning why why do they not
like us it must have been something
we've done must be our foreign policy
and so i asked like okay well let's
let's take let's take our biggest
example let's take osama bin laden what
exactly did we do to this guy i mean was
it was it us aligning with him and the
mujahideen in afghanistan against the
soviets in the 80s we helped him and was
it was it or or was it when we defended
his homeland of saudi arabia from
invasion from iraq from saddam hussein
in the first gulf war
we stopped saddam hussein from invading
saudi arabia
and and that was actually he so he
claimed that our mere presence there
was enough to to radicalize him and
start al-qaeda
this is uh that doesn't make any logical
sense right because we're always looking
for this sort of transactional
relationship
to help us understand as westerners but
they're not westerners they don't
operate off the same logic they think
we're infidels and they hate us because
of who we are and you need to accept
that and that's why it's an endless war
they will always be at war with us and
it will we'll never snuff it out it's
it's a reality that we have to live in
and do you think about it as a religious
struggle or as a criminal enterprise
that's essentially
organized against
the west u.s in particular
i mean it certainly seems to me like a
religious struggle at least that's how
they paint it
um
and uh
you know i could only go off of how they
operate and how they how that's an
interesting question i mean i
i don't know that i distinguish too much
i mean you know it in a sense it
operates like an organized crime
enterprise for sure i mean that's how we
track them we track them through
financing we track them in all the
traditional ways that you might hunt
down a an organized crime unit so in
practical purposes we kind of see it the
same
um
and you know the religious side gets
into it because it goes back to the old
adage winning hearts and minds and
you know
it turns out that yeah that ain't that
easy and they're that we're never gonna
win over
muslims in this sense it's just not
gonna happen
um when we're over there i mean the
alliances that we that we get when we're
in a place like iraq or afghanistan
they're
you know they're they're based on
practicality and look the vast majority
of muslims there are just not that
extreme so they don't
they're fine aligning with us they don't
necessarily subscribe to this idea that
you can't even speak to a
christian um
so it's it's complicated it's complex
life is complicated
so tell me about life as a congressman
you've been a congressman now for three
years and i spent some time in
washington and i was surprised by many
things and overwhelmed by many things
and impressed by many things but what's
your what's your day-to-day life like in
your
so i guess maybe what we first should do
is uh
describe the difference between a
congressman and the senator for
everybody that's listening and then i'd
like to know what you do day to day and
what your fellow congressmen do
mostly senators are just much older
look the the the american system and i
guess i'm just you know what i'm
speaking to the whole audience because
you know there's probably not a lot of
americans that quite understand the
origins of our system but it's not a
parliament you know and um
the reason being
our founders
in creating a republic they wanted it to
move slowly they didn't like this idea
this notion that
the decisions over an entire country
could be made very easily
so they created sort of these national
structures and federal structures and
the house is a national structure the
the senate's of federal structure
and we've kind of changed that over time
and we've we've sort of destroyed that
um by changing the constitution but it
was originally intended
where in the house really represents the
people it's the people's house
your election is every two years it's
very emotional um the majority rules
absolutely i mean nancy pelosi only has
four votes
uh majority and she just kicks our butt
um we can't do we have no power
uh in the house
because it's majoritarian and it's
emotional and it just it just it's the
people it really is
the people
um the senate was supposed to be this
sort of kind of it's like the house of
lords sorta in the great britain
the uk and
and it's supposed to be this sort of uh
slower
or methodical decision-making process
and the constitution was actually
written where there is no popular vote
to elect senators where your state
legislatures actually choose your
senators because the entire point of the
senator
you get two per per
per state and this is important too when
i say federal and national right because
national implies that you're
representing the people so you represent
just based on numbers of people but the
senate isn't like that you know there's
two senators per state
and the reason it's like that is to
is to well give more power to states
that are less populated so they don't
just get run over by everybody else
because the foundation of our country
it's the united states of america the
foundation of our country is this idea
that we can all kind of live together
peacefully if we leave each other the
hell alone for the most part and let
states do what states do
i kind of like that idea i think it
would uh get us out of a lot of our
problems
but the idea was then that states have
representation
and then they choose that now that got
changed in the early 1900s in an
amendment so now it's a popular vote so
the senate got a little bit more
populist it got a little bit more
nationalized but
still a federal entity still two two
votes per state
that that matters um the other big
difference in the senate a senator has
more power individual senator has more
power to block legislation than say i do
in the house
um you know with that power comes more
responsibility so you hope that senators
uh believe in that responsibility one of
the worries i have is that
um we were getting a little bit more of
a kind of a wild west type of senator
getting elected to congress and a little
bit more radicalized the kind of people
you see in the house because it's easy
to be
it's easy to be a purist it's easy to be
a little crazy when you just have no
responsibility and it's easy to kind of
th the diffusion of responsibility is
quite significant in the house there's
435 members but in the senate there's
only a hundred so your your status
actually matters there a little bit more
and you you'd act like an adult um
and for the most part that's how it's
operated
uh you also do that's a four year that's
a four year term uh six years six-year
term six years oh sorry yes
a lot of people don't know this uh it it
just allows you to kind of escape the
political ramifications you know the
emotions of the people for a while and
just kind of make adult decisions and
that's maybe that's a good thing
and um i think the house should probably
be a little bit more you know if i were
to change something i'd say the house
should be three years because we're
running for election constantly it seems
like yeah that's well that is something
i wanted that's something i really did
want to ask you about i just when i went
to washington and met a number of
congressmen congressmen um
both democrat and republican
the first thing i thought was there is
no way i would want to have this job
and the part of it was well when are you
not running for office and that's really
hard and it's really expensive and it's
really demanding and then but you're
also supposed to be working but then
also
you have to fundraise constantly and
that that was really shocking to me my
my sense of it was that congressmen were
spending like 25 hours in an office that
wasn't their primary office on the phone
raising funds for their party and so
that's like 20 hours a week and then you
have to
campaign for like who knows 10 and then
you have to fly because you know you
don't live in washington necessarily and
well then yours then there's your job so
that's got to take up a few hours as
well so i have no idea i have no idea
how you do it and
do can people do it
it's not
it's definitely not glamorous um
and people ask if i enjoy it and i say
well what do you mean by that
um
because i don't enjoy it the way i
enjoyed the seal teams i mean i got
blown up in the seal teams and i still
rather enjoyed it quite a bit uh this is
not enjoyable in the same way now i
personally people who follow me they
know i do a lot of fun things associated
with my campaign that make it enjoyable
like we throw big parties we have a big
fourth of july celebration we do a youth
summit which of course you were you know
you were guesting on i do fun things to
make it enjoyable
and the reason i say it's not quite as
bad as people realize you are correct
that a lot of a lot of folks would say
it's about 20 hours a week am i spent on
the phone fundraising now for me it's
not correct i don't do that at all um i
might spend an hour
and how do you get away with that and
why do other people do it if you can get
away with not doing it why does anyone
do it because i put so much effort into
um into just trying to i try to be
somebody that somebody just wants to
donate to
does that make sense so so i i put a lot
more it makes sense if it works
and if it works
i was under the understanding that
congress people were under congressmen
were under tremendous pressure from
their party brass to to do that sort of
work and you can understand why because
it's so expensive to run maybe it
doesn't have to be you know that is a
question but
um and that gets into a whole other
set of questions um
so to answer your it does work now i'm
very it works for me um it's it's it's
it's hard for
it's hard to uh replicate it to be
perfectly honest
um it works for me because uh
hell i don't know i i know how to use
social media pretty well
um i do things like this right like i
have my own broadcast i know well that's
i want to ask you about that too because
you wrote a book
and just a couple of years ago while you
were doing all this and then you have
this podcast as well and so you are
using this new media to speak directly
to people
and so that begs one question which is
how in the world you have the time to do
all that as well and but i would like to
talk ask you about your experiences with
social media it's like
how is that working for you politically
and what do you think it it signifies
let's say for the future of politics
because who needs the legacy media and
30-second sound bites
it doesn't look to me like anyone does
yeah and and look the entire point of
being a representative is to well
there's a couple points to it
um craft legislation
vote on that legislation so i'm in the
minority which means i'm not really
crafting any legislation i mean i have
legislation i'd like to craft but i have
no power so
my duty is effectively just to vote on
it that doesn't take up a whole lot of
time um
and uh
i i think a lot of members uh
uh gonna mislead the public a little bit
when they say i don't have any time to
read anything uh like look there's ways
that we digest these massive bills um
we're following their their development
over time
staff is combing through it you know
they're they're the reason they're so
long too they're
filled with legal jargon you know and
then you have to break apart the
substantive part of it but there's ways
to
there's ways to absorb it uh so i never
use that as an excuse for why i'm voting
against something because you basically
know what's in it
um
anyway that's sort of a
side point but but you anyway well it's
a relief
that that's true yeah
yeah i just i don't like using that as
an excuse um so it could be an excuse i
just don't like using it um
the but but another big part of your job
is simply to communicate with people
and because you're representing them so
you need to communicate both up and down
right you need to communicate their
voices
uh what you said you would run on so
obviously you don't
perfectly represent everybody there's
lots of democrats in my district who
don't feel that i represent them that's
fine but i represent a majority of the
people in my district and so and i
represent them based on what i ran on a
set of values instead of conservative
limiting principle values
and my job is to is to explain things
better than they can themselves which is
sort of why they elect you they're like
they kind of want you to be like them
but just explain it better
and i knew and i knew that's what i
wanted because i wasn't i was never
political
uh the first moment i got involved in
politics was the moment i declared
running for office
and i always knew so i was a normal guy
is my point like i i think being
involved in politics and being an
activist can kind of
change to change the way you think about
politics and i think
gets you detached from regular people
who are just aren't thinking about it
all the time but i was just one of these
regular people not really thinking about
it all the time i was very interested in
policy
but which is slightly related but
different than politics and so
so when i
so the point is i was kind of of a
regular guy and i knew what i wanted and
i just wanted people to to explain why
the hell they were doing what they were
doing and don't talk to me in talking
points so and and to do that you do need
long-form discussion and then you got to
find you got to communicate with people
where they're at so why do a podcast
well so i can dive deep into issues
and um and be willing and no
know things well enough so that you can
have a long-form conversation a lot of
people will struggle with that
and
and so that's number one but not
everybody listens to podcasts and not
everybody wants to listen to anything
for an hour and so you also have to be
able to communicate your points on
twitter you know and that's not great
but it is something and that's what some
people follow you on so communicate
something there instagram is probably
one of my favorites because i can kind
of do everything on instagram and it's i
have the biggest following there
and um you know you put out videos i put
out explainer videos and i'm not i'm not
giving you a 20-minute you know
uh
informational episode on
on
on issue x but i'm trying to do it in a
couple minutes and go a little deeper
than just democrats are bad
you know and they want to kill jobs well
why do they want to kill jobs you know
let's just let's just explain it a few
layers deep
uh just a few more layers and that's
what people are looking for
and it's been very successful
and so i can spend my time doing that
which is also my job because my job is
to communicate
i can spend my time doing that and
and and being creative with that and
being good at that and that takes away
all those hours of fundraising that i
have to do it's not it's not like i
don't do anything and i'm like and i'm
like one of the number one fundraisers
in the house
oh so that's part of the reason why you
can get away with it
because what you're doing is very
effective right right yeah so tell me
about this youth summit more about the
youth summit and how that got started
and why you do it and what you saw there
i i know i did this q a but
my staff give me things and i do it and
i don't know the context as much as i
would like to especially with something
like that i wish you could have been
there me too
love to get you there next time we'll do
it every year and it's
it's a very cool thing
if you're a conservative you know that
um one of the biggest electoral problems
you have is young people
and uh this isn't all that surprising i
think i think the promises of the
utopian left are very endearing to a
young person and to a certain extent
you'll never escape that
but my goal is to is to give them the
tools of conservatism um there's there's
a lot of youth groups out there
um you're probably familiar with you've
spoken at a turning point event
uh and you maybe you've maybe you've
dealt with yaf too it's a young america
foundation both good organizations but
this isn't what i'm doing i'm not doing
either one of those things i'm trying to
do a mix of both because what yaf does
is
is a very intellectual you know like
it's been ben shapiro's pretty much
their main headliner of course you know
ben well
and um so it's a bit more intellectual
uh there's not a lot of fanfare to it uh
it's just somebody on a stage and let's
give a speech and let's answer some
questions and then you got something
like turning point which is a very high
production
lots it's like a kind of a concert like
very much a rally and um what i try to
do is a mix of both so
get because i i want to give you that
experience
and i'm also 100 only focused on high
school and college kids so that's and
you have to have an age limit so mine
was 24. and
and i want to give them both
intellectual tools that they can come
away with
which is why i invite somebody like you
to speak
and
and i want to also give them a good time
because i know i need to grab their
attention i need them to have fun i need
to i need them to come away with an
experience that they're not going to
forget and so
we just have i mean it's it's a high
production fun event and uh there's like
a there's a there's even a concert in
the middle of it um
you know yeah i don't know what's going
on with the with you conservative types
because you've got comedians now and
you've got entertainment and you know
you're talking to young people it's like
this is very strange so hey i've got a
question about about this issue of you
young people because i've been talking
to lots of conservative folks in canada
uh because we have a conservative party
and they're about as popular as our
government but not quite
and
i i've
mentioned that i believe that their
fundamental problem is that they can't
figure out what they have to offer to
young people but it seems to me that
what they have to offer is
this notion it's something like
encourage something like paternal
encouragement it's like we really think
you could be something if you behave
properly in some essential sense and we
really believe in you as an individual
in alignment with your traditions more
than we believe let's say in the utopian
promises of government per se as a
problem-solving enterprise and i think
one of the things i've really noticed
and i get a lot of letters from people
is that and this just about killed me
when i was on my tour because i'm
offering people words of encouragement
as individuals and i had no idea how
much starvation there was for that
and that was particularly true of young
men but not only true of them and that
is something conservatives can say it's
like look you know we really believe in
you and we we are skeptical of the
claims that big organizations per se
especially government can do what they
promise whereas you as an individual
especially if you get your act together
man you're really something deadly so in
the best possible sense and that's a
that's a really attractive message
especially the young people now because
they don't really hear that
yeah you know they hear that they're
just spoilers of the environment or some
guy wrote me i just opened his letter
today he'd been in prison he'd been
suicidal uh he wasn't a good guy and
he's he sorted his life out when he was
30 about he said he encountered my
lectures and he stopped regarding
himself as intrinsically like an
intrinsically bad despoiler of the
planet something like that i'm not
exaggerating and he had no idea that
maybe there was something to the idea
that he had intrinsic value and he quit
all his idiocy stopped drinking and
stopped taking drugs and he got married
he had a kid and he's got a job and
you know
conservatives have something to offer
young people and they just don't know
how to get it across
there's something about what you're
doing that that does that it's partly
why i'm so interested in talking to you
and why do you think the turning point
thing is working
exactly you know it's just it's
different than what i do i mean what
turning point does what charlie does is
they they're just they just were the
first ones to give
conservative kids a place to go hang out
with each other
frankly um which is
pretty meaningful because people are
just looking for especially in a
university setting
people are desperate to find like-minded
individuals who feel the way they do
they give them that you know the
republican clubs were just kind of
outdated um you know young people don't
go joining these clubs anymore so we
sort of just look for different ways to
do it um
and i i think that's that's that's what
it gives them i mean it's i don't think
it's much more complicated than that
um
but to jump off of what you were saying
about what conservatives deliver
um well somebody asked a question like
that always it kind of depends on my
audience on how i want to answer it but
but jumping off of what you said
you know
um
because you said uh you used the phrase
paternalistic um
encouragement encouragement yeah
of course yeah which is different of
course than paternalism which is i think
a leftist attribute but but what we do
and what i want to jump off of there is
what i often say and actually it was a
speech i gave to that youth summit
was because i'm always trying to explain
to kids like
how how can i'm giving you a tool i'm
giving you a way of explaining something
simply
so that when you're confronted by your
classmate you can have this tool now
you've got a tool in your toolkit that
you can use so i'm like here's a way to
think about the difference between
conservatives and liberals and like it
goes something like this the
conservative ideology is like it's about
love okay
and it's it's about the kind of love
that your parents give you and it's a
little different than say the kind of
love that you're like your crazy aunt
gives you she loves you
but she kind of wants to just spoil you
right she just wants you to love her
it's really important to her she doesn't
really have a lot of responsibility over
you either
so your parents create rules around you
and they tell you that your actions
matter they tell you that you're
accountable they tell you that you
better work hard if you want to succeed
and they're not always that nice about
it you know it doesn't feel like love
but it is in a very profound way that's
love and then your crazy aunt's like
you're perfect the way you are
you know you don't have to change
so you know you're fine and and it's not
your fault that you got a bad grade and
i want to do things for you like let me
take you to the shopping mall it doesn't
mean she's a bad person
it just means that it's that's that's
not there's nothing worse that you can
tell young people especially around 16
or 17 that they're fine the way they are
it's like they might as well just die
right there and then then because
they've hit perfection it's like no
you've got lots more to learn there's
way more to you than you've explored and
it's really necessary that you find that
out and and develop it and that's way
more encouraging than you're okay the
way you are but you know i get it in
some sense because
it's associated with the idea that
people have intrinsic value and if you
have children in some way they are just
perfect the way they are
but in some way they're not because
they're not everything they could yet be
so
yeah so the mess it's easy to get the
message mixed yeah and it's like there's
a difference between uh
not being perfect and being bad you know
and we shouldn't tell kids that they're
just bad but you also have to give them
some room to grow and something to
aspire to and that yeah well that's the
thing right there that that that issue
of something to aspire to you know and
part of the woke uh
what would you call it pathology that
we're all engrossed in at the moment is
the idea that you know that there's
something wrong with judgment per se and
that's such a preposterous idea because
to do it and i could speak about that
psychologically because to do something
like look at a room you have to make
judgments about what you're looking at
and why
you can't do anything without judgment
there's a hierarchy of values it's tied
to our perception
and and there has to be there has to be
something at the top in some sense that
unites us and we should strive for that
and that is the sort of thing that
conservatives can
yeah along with warnings about the
overreach of government because people
who are conservative or tend to be more
concerned about that and so i think the
two things that i like to
say are foundations of conservatism one
we just hit on which is effectively
personal responsibility like sense of
accountability it's a very i think
that's important it's an important
bedrock for any civilization
um i would also say that it's the
precursor to freedom i don't think you
can be a free society if you don't at
least have this sort of sense of
personal responsibility ingrained in it
i don't see how it's possible right
because
for the for the simple reason that
freedom requires a sense of
responsibility
otherwise you're just asking other
people to to be taking care of you and
if you're asking other people to be
taking care of you by definition you're
infringing on their freedoms or you're
asking a politician to infringe on their
freedom so
these are necessary foundations and this
is what conservatives have to authors is
freedom
and we kind of you're also depriving us
you're also depriving yourself of the
adventure of your life
because one one of the things that's
been so successful for me in some sense
is to draw a
connection between responsibility and
meaning it's like you want some meaning
to set against the suffering well where
are you going to find that well
reliably one place to find it is in
responsibility because that means you're
shouldering something worth shouldering
and it's a burden that's actually
somewhat significant and you can you
know you can
comfort yourself with some sense of your
own utility in the face of all your sins
and stupidity and that's that's you
can't how can you live without that i
it's not possible
yeah one of the struggles i have is is
how that's not more persuasive
because there's there's just a lot of
people who just i think fundamentally
disagree with what we're saying right
now they they would disagree that
freedom
as a virtue in and of itself is even a
virtue in and of itself
they would also define freedom very
differently they would say well it can't
be free unless unless you have housing
unless you have health free health care
unless you have unless you have at least
you know some living wage then you can't
go be free
so we're like defining the word freedom
completely differently right because
it's troublesome on the edges too
because you know you can certainly see
that there are levels of absolute
privation that are so severe that your
freedom is restricted in in many ways
not in all ways and maybe not in the
most important ethical ways i mean a lot
i read a lot of literature written by
concentration camp survivors who were in
pretty damn rough situation and still
insisted on their own
what would you say ethical
responsibility certainly solzhenitsyn's
conclusion in some sense he thought that
was all you really had when everything
was stripped away from you and victor
frankl
who i wouldn't regard particularly as a
conservative he pretty much came to the
same conclusion and those are pretty
powerful books it's hard to read through
them without being you know somewhat
convinced so
and
and and i think one of our challenges is
convincing people that freedom is
actually a good thing and maybe not just
not libertine freedom i mean like
ordered liberty freedom you know freedom
within a moral framework which is what
makes me a conservative and not a
libertarian
and
it's just difficult is it more difficult
than you might think to convince people
well i don't know i think you i think
you understand it i think it's a
conversation you have pretty often but
it's convincing people that freedom is
indeed even though it's risky and even
though it's messy and even though it can
allow you to fall on your face sometimes
and and even induce suffering and even
in suffering that you might think is
unjust it's still in the aggregate
improves things it improves everything
and it's harder to see that at the
moment and so what people are swept up
by
is the sort of false promises of of
immediate action
immediate action to save something to
fix something
and to take that paternalistic
government view that status view of
something but the thing is if we
actually took a step back and saw the
forest for the trees and looked at the
long span of history
it is it is always true that more
freedom leads to more prosperity over
time and less of it leads to less
if not if not complete and utter decay
in fact
well i think the diversity argument is
actually a weird
uh what would you call it's a weird
warped version of that in some sense
because speaking as a scientist i hope
part of the reason that freedom works is
that we don't actually know what
problems are going to come up next
because things actually change and they
change in an unpredictable way
and so we have our traditions to guide
us and thank god for that because we'd
be making endless decisions all the time
otherwise and we wouldn't we wouldn't be
we would be in complete disunion but we
still that's not a perfect structure for
moving ahead into unknown territory
okay and so you don't know what the
problems are and you don't know what the
damn solutions are because you're not
that smart so what do you do about that
well biologically what has happened is
that
human beings are possessed of very
diverse individual temperaments and
that's the diversity argument that's why
diversity is necessary but it's
temperamental so there are creative and
non-creative people there are
extroverted and non-extroverted people
there are compassionate people and there
are tough-minded people there are
conscientious people and there are
people who aren't burdened down by duty
and sometimes that frees them up to be
artists let's say who's right well the
answer is it depends on when
and so okay so how do you how do you
cope with that structurally well you let
these diverse people be free so that
they can think up ideas that might be
appropriate for the next problem and
then you let them talk which is why free
speech is so important it's like without
that we do not have a problem-solving
mechanism we can't capitalize this is
biological diversity this is the manner
in which organisms themselves have
adapted to the entire structure of
reality you don't mess with that you
certainly don't do it politically and
you need free speech
you know and it's part of part of that
is also opponent processing you know if
i want to move my hand as smoothly as
possible this way
i put this hand up to stop it and push
and then i can do it
and a lot of the processes that occur
biologically are like that opponent
processes they make for precision and
control and a lot of our political
structures in in the west
because we allow for free discussion our
opponent process
their opponent processes and so we have
a problem we get a diverse range of
opinions god only knows which is right
and then we can talk them through then
maybe we don't implement something you
know catastrophically stupid
and so
i i i think the other point to extract
from what you said is it's diversity
it's also the decentralization principle
yeah yeah right exactly this is a key
key
elements of conservatism is this first
of all a sense of humility uh
conservatism is about a sense of
humility a sense of humility about what
you can really know
and what you can control
and uh in my experience dealing with my
colleagues democrat side they have no
they have no such humility they do
believe that they can solve every
problem and sometimes i think that's
well-intentioned and sometimes it's not
i think it's just important to kind of
extract
you know what what they want but then
but then let us figure out how to get
there yeah well that that actually that
works out temperamentally that's exactly
how things should work because
liberal people all you know insofar as
psychologists have been able to
determine this and it's not exactly
accurate because psychology as a field
is prejudice against conservatives so
some of the scientific measures are
biased yeah it's terrible especially in
social psychology but but none that well
let so so
the the people who tend towards those
more liberal utopian and grand scheme
views are they tend to be high in
openness and that's creativity divergent
thinking and low in conscientiousness
they're not very detail-oriented
whereas the conservatives are the
opposite types and so what you see
happening in businesses is the open
liberal types tend to be entrepreneurial
at least in their vision and the
conservative types implement and if you
don't get that right in your business
then it doesn't work because the open
people they're everywhere they can't
settle down they can't even catalyze an
identity easily because they're
interested in everything and they're
full of wild schemes and great because
hey some ideas but if you want
implementation
and then the other problem with the
grand scheme thing is and conservatives
always say this and it's really hard to
teach young people about this but it's
really important and that's the law of
unintended consequences it's like why
are you so sure that your stupid idea
will only do what you think it will do
and not a hundred weird things that you
don't predict at all that are worse than
the original problem and this this could
lead us into a discussion of climate
change politics for example i've been
watching the spot price of oil and and
natural gas as well and what's happening
in china which has just cut power to
millions of people because coal prices
have gone through the roof and they're
trying to meet their carbon targets
so it's like yeah well that's a solution
is it well let's talk about that a bit
maybe if you don't mind because i see
you're on that committee you just talked
to bjorn lomberg
yeah we just have a podcast it's um it's
a subject i primarily deal with most
people probably think i'm on armed
services committee and
primarily deal with national security
issues but my two issues are healthcare
and environment
mostly i i don't know i i've always
tended to have a uh
to gravitate towards weaknesses um
and and i feel like those are the two
subjects that uh conservatives are
weakest on in our messaging even if i
think we're correct about our
assessments of them
um
uh you know can i say one more thing
about the decentralization part yeah
conservatism and then let's move into
climate change we've got a lot to say
about climate change
um
but like one of the reasons i think this
is so important this this sense of
humility it also it also helps people
understand i'm always trying to help
people understand what the philosophical
underpinnings are why you're a
conservative because i think there's a
really rich tradition there and i don't
think there is one on the left right i
think the left is about what you want
right now and i don't see it guided by
any kind of principle or especially and
if there's there's no governing
principles in there either no limiting
principles and so
the decentralization argument is
important and it gets to the diversity
argument because it's it's really why we
come it's why it's why we end up
supporting the free market
all right it's why we think that is
important because
like while it will never be perfect and
while you can always imagine a utopia
where the centralized thinking just
makes things better it never works and
there's a good reason it never works
and in the entire point of that
diversity and in the free market that
underpins it
is the ability to
to do something and then test out
whether it's creating value or not you
know because yeah you can be that
whimsical artist if you want but if
nobody cares about it then it's a good
indication that you're not creating any
real value but of course some people do
and they find a way to do that and i
just think that's it's as good an
indication as you can get
and that's the thing that makes it so
tough is that
we we produce these decentralized
processes and they're actually cognitive
computational devices the environment's
unbelievably complex it's impossible to
keep up with it so you distribute
decision making and that is a
fundamental conservative principle to to
the in the most diverse possible manner
right right down to the level of the
individual because you're too damn
stupid to know what's coming
and so you need to build a computational
machine and that that's really perhaps
how conservatives should talk about it
because that link is very seldomly made
how do you keep up with an infinitely
complex environment with a infinitely
complex mobile economy that's so diverse
that you can't predict what it's going
to do you certainly can't control it and
you shouldn't and maybe someone
somewhere will keep up a bit and then
you can copy them that's a deal man
and i and i think it's a good one and
it's actually a good it's a good segue
into the climate change debate so so
cause what the left will say is okay
well there's market failures
free market seems nice but there's
market failures you have to admit that
and i would say yeah i can admit that
uh it can happen and uh that's where
environmentalism comes from right
there's uh
there's externalized costs and yeah yep
and and that's that's effectively the
argument about climate change but then
but then you got to put your
conservative hat back on and say okay
again a primary tenant of conservatism
is assessing trade-offs uh because i i
would i would say conservatism is a
governing philosophy it's a
process-oriented philosophy that's that
seeks to solve problems within a set of
limiting principles
limiting principles means we ask
questions like what are the second third
order consequences what's the cost
benefit and that's really what
the climate change debate should be
about unfortunately it's not about that
it's about you're a denier and a killer
or you want to save the planet like a
good person uh which one do you want to
be you know they moralize over us on it
but it really is fundamentally about um
about trade-offs and so
you know the the the republican
mainstream position on this isn't
denying climate change right it's it's
just assessing the facts and saying okay
there's certainly some warming going on
there's certain loop warming i would say
uh i'm just going to use the same data
that everybody else is using uh let's
let's use the un data let's use the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
and let's see what they're saying or the
costs are going to be
and so
their cost is the simplest way to put
this is yeah there's a cost
and how do we
how do we quantify that cost well we can
look at it this way according to the u.n
again the the scientific consensus
uh we're going to increase global gdp by
450 percent uh in 100 years
uh well by 2100 with climate change
costs it's gonna look more like an
increase of only 434 percent
so it's a cost but it ain't that much
okay and so again we're not denying it
but we are saying look whatever actions
we take need need to be in somewhat
proportional to that cost
um and that would be a good place to
start
um well that's how i liked lomberg so
much is he was the only i'm really
interested in environmental issues i
studied them for a long time
and tried to figure out you know what
what bothered me about most of the
environmentalist discussion was there
was no rank ordering of priorities and
that was re that's a real problem if you
want to implement some solutions and i
came across lomberg and i thought hey
look this guy he's got a
he's got a sensible way of actually
generating policy out of this right he
put his teams of economists to work and
does cost-benefit analysis and tries to
build something approximating what would
be a policy-generating machine he he
takes projections of precisely the sort
that you just made into account and that
market failure idea we could we could
talk about that a little bit
it's like well of course the market
fails because even a decentralized
cognitive machine made up of all these
millions or billions of human brains
isn't going to be perfect
but that's not the issue the issue is
what makes you think that you can jump
into that gap with your theory
and fix it if the bloody market can't do
it why in the world do you think you can
well because i have an ideology it's
like oh yeah you and everyone else
and dealing with market failures is is
essentially what politicians are
supposed to it's why we create a
government to to deal with markets so
deal with poverty i mean you could argue
that
poverty excessive poverty might be a
market failure like it's just not
getting fixed now
now you really think about it you know
there's always going to be somebody at
the bottom but you don't want him to be
too far at the bottom
and so so this is this is where you have
a value-based judgment and and you have
a political
argument about it you kind of figure out
what to do but you know the the the the
problem with what the left does is say
this is an indication that the entire
system is bad and we need to throw out
the foundations the conservative says
it's an indication we might need to take
some action and we should and we should
be very careful about how we take that
action and we should do so within a set
of limiting principles and it's that's a
difficult sell because and it gets back
to the climate change debate because
it's a difficult cell because because
the liberal will say what do we want
action when do we want it now what does
it consider
what do we want uh incremental change
when do we want it in due time yes
exactly it's just it's not that exciting
especially the young people
um so you know there's that principle in
science occam's razor right do not
multiply explanatory hypotheses beyond
necessity which is the simplest solution
is by default the most appropriate
now the same thing might apply with
regards to problems and that's another
conservative advantage in some sense
it's like no no the smallest possible
change
that will produce the end result right
because you don't know what the change
is going to do and and that uncertainty
that's part of that humility of
conservatism that you described that is
something that's communicable to young
people it's like it's not like we don't
think
we don't think there are problems but
we're also quite skeptical of grandiose
solutions and even more skeptical of the
people who put them forward
yeah and and that's not foolish at all
i'm much more afraid of the people
dealing with climate change than i am of
climate change
as you should be because what we're
i mean well so this week we're debating
um this reconciliation bill and
reconciliation just means that you can
pass it through the senate with only 51
votes instead of the 60 vote threshold
required to
overcome the filibuster and that means
it has to be related to budget items
okay so that not that anybody cares
about that but that's what we're
debating and within that big 3.5
trillion which is actually closer to
four and a half trillion depending on
how you estimate it
um there's a lot of you know let's call
it green new deal provisions um
and what a green new deal basically is
is massive subsidies for solar and wind
massive incentive structures for only
solar and wind and renewables
but renewables they really just define
as solar and wind okay they don't like
hydro they don't like nuclear
and uh we'll get to that
um so it's that and also a full-on
attack against the oil and gas industry
which should also trouble canadians uh
hey we're we're plenty troubled by it
that's for sure yeah i mean when even
trudeau is like hey why did you guys
cancel the excel for the the keystone
pipeline yeah but he's secretly happy
about it yeah that's true
um
so so this simultaneous attack is
is unbelievably dangerous uh for the
well-being of people across the globe
um it's gonna
so you so right away you're gonna see
increases in energy prices um you
already see it in place how much how
much what are we gonna see in two years
what do you think 300 bucks a barrel
oh oil geez no no i don't
that the the data i see doesn't say that
but you could get up to 90. i just read
a wall street journal article today that
some estimates are at 90 by the end of
the year which is pretty damn high
i don't know about 300 i mean but but i
don't know if they passed this bill and
it was
implemented their natural gas tax which
would put a lot of our medium-sized
producers out of business yeah just
exactly
and also take away
take away the one thing that has
decreased carbon emissions
that's fracking haha fracking now which
democrat would have predicted that
zero
nobody no one predicted that man and it
was just you know
nobody nobody that's right no because it
just kind of happened um it's a free
market it just it just kind of happened
and it happened because of a government
action but the government action was
just liberalizing it it was just it was
just it was just removing a barrier to
it and the export ban
that even obama signed uh
when we removed the oil export ban out
of the united states what did you just
create well you created a powerhouse of
energy in the united states
and why is that a good thing does that
make climate change worse or better well
the question isn't that's that's the
wrong question really because the
question is what is demand for energy
around the world
and so it turns out demand for energy in
the next 20 years is going to go up
almost 30 percent that's a guarantee
so who's going to provide that energy um
it's not going to be solar and wind
all estimates show it's going to have
about its same
same proportion of the energy mix
and so it's either going to be the
united states and canada that actually
care about environmental regulations and
put all these restrictions and you know
um on a per unit basis and this is a
this is a scientific estimate
it's not the epa that did it it was um
one of our national labs that did this
estimate
uh
a unit of natural gas is 42 less
emissions than a russian uh unit of
natural gas
so we're cleaner we're like we're
objectively cleaner when we're when
we're giving you oil and gas
and yet this administration
counter-intuitively in an effort to
reduce gas prices wants opec to increase
production so we're tacking u.s oil and
gas and and trying to get opec to
increase their production this is if
you're trying to solve the problem of
reduction of emissions this is yeah
they're not exactly our friends always
no and and they they want to put we see
this play out in canada madly
yeah and so it's just it's just same
thing's happening in canada with regards
sorry sorry
well i'm just saying if we're if we're
trying to solve a problem you know of
reducing emissions then then fine let's
solve the problem and the other thing we
as republicans are always wondering is
wait a second if you really think this
is an existential threat and we're done
and like we're cooks in 12 years the
world is on fire as they always say
well then why not just instead of the
trillions of dollars towards a bunch of
nonsense
why not just build a bunch of nuclear
plants really why not just build a bunch
of nuclear plants why don't you have
just government so what's the answer to
that yeah why not like france did it
their answer is um
well there's the truthful answer there's
the public answer and there's the real
answer that i think is true but so
they're publicly hero you know
their answer is well it's expensive
there's safety issues i'm like yeah but
on a per unit basis it's it's still a
better deal again if you think i thought
i thought no cost was too high because
we're in an existential crisis and so i
would assume that you think it's
priority to have reliable energy and you
don't get reliable energy from solar and
wind and you never will it's impossible
and i don't care how far along the
battery technology comes it'll never
meet where we need it to meet it just
won't it's physically not going to
happen
and so you need nuclear and you need gas
but they're against it they're shutting
down gas nuclear plants in california
and new york
and
it's just it's just it's really
mind-blowing so it leads me to believe
that they don't actually one they don't
actually think it's a crisis
um and and two that they're mostly
driven by special interests in the solar
and wind industries that have really
captured them and again i'm not against
solar and wind i just think i just think
they should fit in where they fit in
i i don't think they should be over
subsidized at this point i think there
should be technology neutral subsidies
for carbon reduction
um that involve nuclear and it also
involve carbon capture for oil and gas i
mean if the entire point is reducing
carbon emissions and let's make that the
technology goal as opposed to just
renewables because it makes us feel nice
and it really is about feelings i mean i
i i don't think there's any other
reasoning behind it
oh there's there is another reason i
think is that
the ideological morass out of which such
ideas emerge is extraordinarily confused
and it's you know 30 percent
anti-capitalism and
20 percent what would you say resentment
about the nature of humanity itself and
then 40 percent
concern about the environment and our
depredations and so you have that mix
you can't think clearly it's like well
are we saving the environment yeah but
what about capitalism because it's
actually the problem to begin with and
so then you get these sorts of solutions
emerging and a lot of them are tainted
with this terrible destructive
anti-capitalism and which seems to be
often more a more important crisis than
the environmental crisis itself
yeah i mean you look at the green new
deal um and what aoc wrote up this sort
of like children's science project
it was very little about the environment
and much more so about the substantive
change in health care and the economy
and uh it it was kind of it's kind of
saying the quiet part out loud which we
all suspected that this was mostly about
uh you know the sort of great reset that
people talk about it kind of it's kind
of more about that than it is climate
change but for you to to get you to
agree to these really substantive
reforms to the sort of revolution and
thinking they need to scare the hell out
of you which is why they use terminology
like the world is on fire and it's why
they point to every hurricane and
wildfire like this is what climate
change looks like i mean you hear that
all the time
but it's it's really as if we've never
had hurricanes as if we'd never had
wildfires and as if there's not actually
a much better explanation for california
wildfires which is poor forest
management which every study shows
right it's like let me get this straight
if we all drive electric vehicles today
if we if if the united states stops
producing carbon today
are you telling me there's no more
wildfires are you telling me all of our
weather starts to look like san diego
are you telling me houston's not gonna
have hurricanes anymore that's that's
nonsense i mean that's complete nonsense
and it's it's not data driven it's not
fact-driven
um
and and truthfully again go back to un
intergovernmental planning and climate
change data if the western world believe
all developed countries if they stopped
emitting carbon right now for good uh
you might get a reduction in temperature
of i think it's like 0.8 degrees
fahrenheit by the year 2100 right right
and that's what that that's actually
within the error bounds so one of the
problems with these climate projections
is that if you go out 50 years
you can't even tell if what you did 50
years ago had worked because the error
bars become are so big at that point and
that's actually a huge problem because
what it means is there's no way of
testing whether your dam solution your
large-scale solution had any effect
whatsoever
so how in the world are you supposed to
solve a problem like that
it's you can't
and but immediately like it's like we
don't want to do anything right i mean i
listed some things that republicans are
in favor of and uh primarily nuclear
energy and gas i think i think that's a
healthy that puts us on a healthy glide
path towards reduction in emissions and
and look the other truth is is the more
a country develops the more you
industrialize it the more concern they
become about the environment that's
another truth so maybe focus on yes
definitely well also you know with the
lefty types you think well they're
concerned with poverty reduction okay
well how to do that well how about you
make energy real cheap
how about that because
energy is what does work and so if you
give that to poor people for as close to
nothing as possible then they can do
almost everything free
how would that be so are you are you so
sure you're concerned about those
poverty-stricken people if you look
historically can you really imagine
anything that has done more for them
than cheap energy and how would that
even be possible even metaphysically
energy runs everything
so cheap energy means wealth
directly oh virtually no intermediation
so now you're going to make every energy
all more expensive to produce these
trivial changes in
in climate that you won't even be able
to measure
it's like what's up with you exactly
yeah it's it's true and it's just it's
such a frustrating conversation um i i
do think
we're winning the debate on this because
it's not a winning argument to say
there's no such thing as climate change
uh the environment doesn't need our help
that's just people don't want to hear
that
um
but but they would just want to hear
something and and so and that's i think
that's what we've
we're offering at this point and so i
think we're on a healthy track
as republicans uh i
i am still very worried about this bill
that has the potential of passing but
you know hey let me ask you about that
infrastructure bill okay because i mean
i've thought
and
and talked to many people about this
that you know
if the democrats need something to do
because they need something to do and
they're in power and
well maybe infrastructure isn't such a
bad preoccupation there's something real
about it hopefully at least maybe 30
percent of it which might not be bad
given you know large projects waste a
lot always
and so
pros and cons of the infrastructure
project as far as you're concerned yeah
the um so there's two things for for
people's understanding there's this
reconciliation package you hear the
number 3.5 trillion associated with that
so that's one thing and then there's the
infrastructure the bipartisan
infrastructure deal which is like 1.23
trillion
still a lot of money the the bipartisan
infrastructure deal
substantively is not bad it does a lot
of good things right like what like what
what do you see that's good it's it's
just your typical boring infrastructure
stuff like like highway funding um like
port funding uh sewage treatment this
kind of stuff okay yeah it's boring when
it works it's legitimately yes exactly
it's legitimately decent infrastructure
our opposition to it again it's not
everybody's opposed to it but my
personal opposition to it is
it's it's about four times three to four
times too much money
yeah that's about what you'd expect
though yeah and it you know it's just if
if it was cut in half at least you could
get me scratch in my head like maybe
but it is important for people to know
the substance of it is not bad it's it's
yeah the price tag is just too much um
considering we've spent six trillion on
on getting our economy back on on track
over covid which frankly was mostly
money well spent it's probably some of
the best work government has done in
crisis to be honest especially with the
small business loan program that we
instituted here in the us but
it's um
in any case
it's not the time to just be throwing
money out the door you know with piper
inflation coming about it you just need
to be more careful
uh is is really our only opposition to
the infrastructure bill so that's and
what about the three so now you
separated out the 1.2 trillion which
you're speaking reasonably positively
about for you know a suspicious
conservative type and then there's the
3.5 trillion so let's talk about that
and and
you know because the fear was that
everything would be put into that basket
right of course that's going to happen
so yeah
detail out that yeah so the
reconciliation package is a series of
tax hikes um about two over two trillion
dollars in tax increases three quarters
of which will indeed despite what the
democrats say they're lying about this
because we have liberal think tanks that
have done assessments and it will will
increase taxes on at least three
quarters of low lower to middle income
people will increase your taxes is it
because there's so many different types
of tax increases
uh and it's gonna hit you somehow and if
it doesn't hit you there it's probably
gonna reduce your wages so we've already
seen how much how much are people
looking about being hit by about one
percent uh which is it's not a ton but
it's something but i think i think
what's worse about the way democrats do
economic policy it's not like it's going
to make your wages noticeably decrease
immediately but i'll tell you what
they're not going to increase
and and i have proof of this you know if
we look at the last 15 years of data
post so let's look at two major
recessions one coveted and one's 2008
financial crisis and two different types
of two different types of economies two
different types of governing
philosophies
and the first time was
under obama
we need more attack we need to tax the
rich and just
spend money on infrastructure they had
this nearly trillion dollar
infrastructure package back then turned
out everybody agrees now that turned out
to be a waste did not contribute to the
economy the way we hoped it would the
shovel-ready myth okay every that's
that's widespread agreement on that in
hindsight
at the time i can understand why you
might think that stimulus is important
but in hindsight didn't work out okay
but you're also increasing taxes you're
you're a threat to businesses because
you like to regulate them and you you
they tend to see businesses as more of a
bad actor than a good actor that creates
investment in jobs
okay and so then so fast and so what did
that create well it created
plenty of wealth for the top everybody's
mad about inequality
under that system the tops still get
richer because they could figure it out
but the bottom quintile of earners was
stagnant so that's not a myth that was
true
now after the tax cuts and jobs act in
2017 is you know trump's major
accomplishment obviously
anyway the tax cuts and jobs act so
um what do we do we cut corporate tax
rates cut everybody's
taxes everywhere right tax cuts for
everybody
and what happens to wages well if you
look at wage growth um the bottom
quintile of earners skyrocketed now it
doesn't mean that it like drastically
reduced inequality okay
but as far as a proportion goes a
percentage goes the bottom people were
growing much much faster than the top
now in absolute terms obviously not and
that's what everybody looks at right
they want to take the data that they
care about and it makes their argument
stronger so they'll say yeah but they
made 100 million dollars more
well okay well there were 50 they had 50
billion dollars so percentage-wise they
didn't make that much more but the
lowest quintile
you know doing this particular job which
you know i i don't know what a universe
you could imagine where that particular
job is making that much more but they
were growing why because well
pro-growth economic policies create a
tight labor market right where
businesses have to compete to hire
people we're at a very tight labor
market now wages are
now thanks to biden but mostly because
of the pandemic and a few other things
but wages are pretty high i mean it is
still hard to hire people
um
you know this bill could reverse that
because look the reality is is that
biden economics has not really hit the
united states because they haven't done
any they haven't passed anything
all right they're they're they've
created this sort of they've what
their
general
view on business that it's bad
and and the increase in regulations has
i think decreased investment but that's
hard to measure i i think it's intuitive
and obvious but other than that there
hasn't been a major shock to the system
all right a lot of the a lot of the
shocks are maybe too much spending and
also supply chains problems uh which are
more related to the pandemic um
and maybe it may be a refusal of this
administration to do anything about it
and loosen certain restrictions so it's
a long long anyway the point is is pro
growth works and it actually helps
increase wages for the lowest quintile
inverters that's just a that's a data
driven in fact that we could look at
over the past decade or so so getting
back to this reconciliation package it's
just doing the opposite it's just doing
the opposites you're going to reduce
wages more importantly reduce their
potential growth because
you're also creating an environment
because you're raising corporate tax
rates so businesses are just going to
hire less right it's never the ceo that
gets hurt because of a corporate tax
hike it's just this absurd notion that
that you're just like taking it to the
taking it to these mean corporations
yeah what these corporations that employ
hundreds of thousands of people
what is it you know
it doesn't mean they should just do
whatever they want no it is it is the
inequality in some sense that that
bothers people but one of the things
that i have trouble with with regards to
to leftist policies is that they
actually underestimate the severity of
the problem of inequality and they
assume that restructuring capitalism
would remove inequality and there's
absolutely no evidence whatsoever that
that has ever worked in any way other
than the opposite because inequality is
not a consequence of capitalism it looks
like it's almost like a physical
property of the of reality itself i mean
there are physicists who model
the unequal distribution of money using
the same equations they use to describe
the dispersion of gas into a new
environment like it's a really something
fundamental it can't be overstated and
it's a real problem right because who
the hell wants terribly poor people like
that's such a catastrophe
but it's not like
it's a consequence of
capitalism it's like come on guys the
other thing about inequality
it's just it's a look let's look at the
following math problem if there's if you
and i are the
the sole citizens of country x
you make fifty thousand dollars a year
and i make a hundred thousand dollars a
year well there's a delta between us of
fifty thousand dollars
now let's both double our income so now
you make a hundred thousand dollars and
i make two hundred thousand dollars well
holy crap inequality just doubled
because now there's the hundred thousand
dollar delta so it's not always what
people think i mean the
the question isn't necessarily about it
because i don't care that there's a lot
of people who are way way wealthier than
me it doesn't necessarily bother me what
would bother me is if i have no chance
of ever being them if i was the most
talented smartest person on the planet
it would bother me if i had no chance of
ever being that person
and i'm sorry but this is not the world
we live in
you know there's there's if we look at
if what keeps you out of poverty and i
think it's from the brookings institute
there's like three things it's like
finish high school have a job any job
and don't have kids before you're
married and you've got like a 97 chance
of not being in poverty so it turns out
we do live in a society where choices
matter and and you're
and the value that you provide matters
and that's the society we want to live
in is it perfect no is it the best we
can do yeah i'm pretty sure it is
and should we have a safety net for
those who just can't make it yeah yeah
there should be a safety net
um but you know we should argue about
how much of a safety net and then the
fundamental and about the negative
consequences of that potentially as well
right because you know safety net it
doesn't make things worse
it makes you dependent and makes you
unable or unwanting to find more work
and be productive right that would be
the fundamental question of a safety net
and and i think their democrat policies
just generally don't care about that um
so can i dig in can i dig into the weeds
on the three i still don't understand
the differentiation between the 1.2
trillion and the 3.5 trillion oh yeah
yeah so i got a long way to go on the
left here so
let me let me do it um more generally
instead of getting too much into the
weeds on the taxation stuff so okay so a
lot of increase in taxes a lot of
increase in spending a lot of that
increase in spending is on things like
expanding medicaid right expanding
medicare like making medicare benefits
more generous um even though like 96 of
the medicare population already gets a
dental envision and whatever so it's
just it's a lot of to me it's a lot of
bribery okay it's like we're giving you
stuff um we're gonna fund like the pre-k
we're gonna fund all of these things
through the government we're just gonna
do so many things any wish list they've
ever had they're sticking in this bill
um again the subsidies subsidies for
solar and wind
just you know a new climate bank
whatever the hell that means i mean with
for with tens of billions of dollars in
it it's it's stuff like that that is um
you know some of it is extremely
threatening i think to because of a
policy perspective and some of it's just
incredibly wasteful so that's where you
see the over-inclusiveness of the
infrastructure development project
that's where everything is being
shoveled into yeah yeah so again it is
separate from the infrastructure bill
what we call the infrastructure bill and
the reconciliation package remember i
remember when if if people remember when
the democrats were talking about human
infrastructure like everything is
infrastructure right right uh they put
all the human infrastructure into the
reconciliation package and we kept the
real we kept the real infrastructure in
the infrastructure package so again
substantively speaking i think the
infrastructure package is good i just
think it's too expensive and
substantively speaking i think the
reconciliation package is complete
insanity
okay well let's close that off there
because we're going to run out of time
here there's some other things if you
don't mind i wanted to ask you about
we'll pop out of the political domain to
some degree to to begin with you have a
book you wrote a book not too long ago
and so maybe you could well tell
everybody what what the book is and and
then talk about that a bit if you'd like
to sure appreciate it um fortitude
american resilience in the era of
outrage
and um
came out with this book in april of 2020
uh
interesting time to come out with a book
as you can imagine that was the start of
the bandana i've never really done a
book tour
um but it's done pretty well and i think
it's done pretty well because it's sort
of you know i i'll be honest i kind of
describe it as like a jordan peterson 12
rules for life but like the jv version
okay it's like the it's like if you're
if you're the if you're the post-grad
level like i'm trying to give people a
bit more of a high school level
of the similar thing
and i'm very and specifically
trying to guide people through how to
build more fortitude more mental
fortitude
um
and i use a combination so every
chapter's a different lesson sort of a
different concept that i'm trying to
ingrain
and it's a
those lessons and concepts are
imparted to the reader through a series
of stories from the seal teams
um
through some philosophy there's some
bible verses
and there's some pop culture uh you know
it's a mix of everything i think it's
multidisciplinary
and i think it's interesting i i think
it's unique and i think that's why it's
sold pretty well
um
and it's it's so where did you learn
where did you learn to to be resilient i
mean after you were terribly injured you
went back and continued in your opera
military operations
i mean that seems to be i mean some
resilience you know it's it's you're
healthy and you're tough and
that's part of what's built into you
it's a gift in some sense but then
there's the role that attitude plays and
and education and all of that and
i was fortunate enough to meet a number
of navy seals in california and got to
know some of them quite well and you
know they're very respectable characters
and they go through hell to become navy
seals that's quite interesting they told
me some pretty hair-raising stories and
um where did you learn to be resilient
to the degree that you learned it was
that mostly military was that mostly a
military consequence well of course like
any development i think it's a
consequence of
a lot of experiences but i would what i
write about in the book my first
experience and
this experience is laid out in um
in a chapter called perspectives from
darkness and um enabled at that chapter
because one of the first
foundations of fortitude
being you know if we define fortitude is
resilience to it
the ability to overcome adversity
and um perspective is a pretty good
place to start because if you think
everything is worse than it is you're
gonna have a hard time mentally coping
with it
uh if you have a sense of perspective
you're able to you know what this isn't
that bad like one of the one of the
things one of the things instructors in
buds this is seal training repeat to
students constantly is
look there's ten thousand men who have
done this before you so stop you're
complaining
you can do this and that's a that's like
a quick gut check like god i don't want
to be one of those who just quit i mean
there's 10 000 that have done it before
it's probably more than that to be
perfectly honest but and so but but what
i write about is is um my mother
because you know i think that was my
first real interaction with some kind of
fortitude she she she lost her when you
were 10. yeah right yeah and i also you
know i watched her deal with breast
cancer for five years and
and i had trouble recalling
uh real suffering on her part mostly
because she hid it from me
and i have trouble recalling her
complain i have trouble
recalling her have a bad attitude i have
lots of other recollections of her being
funny of her being nice of her being a
good mother
wow and it sort of begs the question
like how does how on earth can someone
do that it's extremely difficult and not
show that kind of resentment and
bitterness um
and just raise your kids and so
that's that's sort of that's my first
hero
um
you know first hero to look at i also
have a whole chapter on heroism and
frankly i got some of that philosophy
from you
um on how to build hero archetypes and
and the proper way to look up to people
uh as a way to develop yourself in a
better way right and i say like don't
take an individual like you don't want
to just be like jordan peterson you want
to kind of see what makes him successful
see how he's done well in his life and
maybe copy some things from him like how
does he talk to people how does he think
through things what's the thought
processes he used and how does that
apply to the hierarchy you want to be
better in because it might be different
like you know you might be an academic
you might be in media it might be in
sports like it's
it's different so you got to look up to
people within your own
genre really and the seal teams is no
different because what am i trying to be
a better seal a better leader so what
makes somebody something that i want to
follow
uh so that's like that's chapter two for
instance one of my favorite chapters i
think it's it's a good way to start like
how because you got to know what you
want to if you want to be somebody who
lives with fortitude you got to know
what that looks like first right you got
to know what you're aspiring to it's a
really important thing you can look at
you can look at what you admire
spontaneously like obviously you admired
your mother spontaneously and so that's
an instinct that's not that's not
rational exactly although it might be
hyper rational you know and we all have
that instinct to admire and that does
point us in the direction of what is
better
yeah exactly and it's just
in a practical way in kind of a
materialistic way it's like well just
what works
like what are the outcomes that actually
work for people and what don't and
one of the problems with post-modernism
is is trying to make the things that
don't work make them work like socialism
hasn't been tried you know it's like
that kind of thing right because it
feels good
and and so you know then my second real
uh interaction i suppose with fortitude
yeah would be the military i mean buds
is a trial by fire you come out a
different person than you went in um how
how were you different how were you to
begin with that's the first question and
then how are you different well i just i
think you come i mean look i just
i think maybe i'll maybe i'll take that
back a little bit i guess i'll say
because one thing we say in the sales
teams is
you were sealed before you got here we
just made you prove it and then we
trained you
but that mental capacity it had to be
there because you wouldn't make it
through hell week otherwise
so you had it but you hadn't proven it
to anybody and you hadn't proven it to
yourself
and once you prove it to yourself that's
something i mean you become something a
little different not too different but
it's a little different
um and some people can become cocky
right you don't want to be too cocky you
want to be confident so you definitely
become more confident i don't think
you've met many seals who aren't very
confident in themselves
and
and so that's a good but that's they
weren't cocky they were most of them
were unbelievably funny they're
unbelievably humorous and and i i think
i'm very funny
you know and i'm not being overly
confident i think i'm very funny i'm
just
humility's not an attribute that we have
very much of
and
so
it's yeah it changes you i mean it
there there's a culture like i can
identify a team guy
really easily um
first of all there's definitely a look
right there and it's but there's a way
there's something in their eyes like i
can just tell like what you've i can
just tell
and i don't know how to describe it um
to be honest with you and because we all
kind of come from the same place where
we wanted to do this particular job we
wanted to go through the hardest
training we could find
and be in this elite team and so that
that
i don't know it just it makes you
similar in some way even though there's
i think a decent amount of diversity in
the teams
um as far as backgrounds go as far as
backgrounds and wealth come from i mean
it's it's very very difficult to
it's also very difficult to see who's
going to make it through it um this gets
to another chapter which i call no plan
b
and
you can't get through buds unless you
unless you decided that you would die
before you quit um you have to you have
to have given yourself no choice in the
matter
um that's the only way you make it
through if you're like you know what i'm
gonna do that's like marriage yeah
well okay that's a funny story because
because one of the one of the sayings in
in the sale teams is the only easy day
was yesterday
and uh that that that motto is plastered
on the buds grinder
and so uh what me and my wife did
knowing understanding that that
there's so many so many good parallels
between seal trading and marriage we
went and took our some of our wedding
photos right in front of that sign the
only easy day was yesterday um and it's
it's it's sort of this no quit attitude
and this understanding that look it's
only things get harder so what deal with
it
um it's and and and
embrace it embrace the suck i'm just
kind of using slogans from the seal
teams at this point but but they had
they have quite a bit of meaning
associated with them embrace the suck
and what does that mean fundamentally
well they have meaning because people
are actually acting them out right
they're not empty slogans it's so
they might be comical represent
oversimplified representations but
there's something actually happening
and i like that particular one embrace
the suck because it actually gets to
another chapter in the book which is
simply called do something hard and the
whole point of of this discussion is
embrace suffering i'm not saying embrace
like
swimming with sharks because you can
suffer swimming with sharks and getting
bitten like that would suck
but
um
i mean self-imposed suffering right and
so like buds and how weak and everything
we do and still try it all is
self-imposed like you you do you you do
have it in the back of your minds like
i'm not going to die i'm not actually
going to die feels like i'm going to die
feels like they're trying to kill me um
but but i know i know that they're going
to save me if i start drowning and
people do drown and uh but we saved them
okay
and
it's funny but it's
it's it's it's horrible but it's funny
um
but but there's a but there's a real
value um to seeking out challenge and
suffering this is why people do spartan
races this is why people come together
and they love group suffering too this
is why people go go organize themselves
at crossfit gyms and and do these crazy
things why you go climb a mountain right
like is it for the view did you climb
the mountain for the view no no no you
did it
the the means were the entire point like
the path that you took was the entire
point because it's hard
and um i i think that's pretty normal
and intuitive and i think that's been a
really fundamental tenet of americanism
for a very long time and i think we're
losing it which is why i felt i had to
write about it more and just kind of
remind people of why these things are
important i don't think there's anything
novel in my book at all well you are a
conservative
yeah yeah
right i just i just think it's a i just
think what i did was take all the best
ideas from history and try to lay them
out for people because you know if
you're trying to come up with something
novel these days there's a it's a good
chance that you're probably just wrong
about it um because it hasn't stood the
test of time i think it's very rare that
there's going to be really new insights
in in today's world um
and it might i think i think the new
insights are really just the old ones
like personal responsibility and doing
hard things and challenging yourself and
just and feeling good about a challenge
even if it sucks even if it's an
injustice like i dive into that quite a
bit in that because because that's
people's next question it's like well
how can you say all suffering is good
like even injustice even things that
happened to you like what if you lose
your eye and go blind i mean like what
you know
well
then just look at the silver lining i
mean it's
i i'm oversimplifying it quite a bit
there's a much i think deeper discussion
in the book
but it really does just simplify to look
at the silver lining just because
there's an injustice done against you
doesn't mean you have to tell yourself
that story
doesn't mean you have to tell yourself a
story of being a victim
um you can be a victor even if it's
false like even if you really are a
victim now i think people over victimize
themselves these days to an
extraordinary degree i think they
either lie about their victimhood or
they or they associate victimhood with
bad luck you know and there's a
difference right and
in either case though it doesn't
actually change how you should react to
it
and you can react like a person with
fortitude and tell yourself a story of
being better for it and being a victor
or you can tell yourself a story of
being a victim and see where that leads
you and i promise you won't lead you
anywhere good
i think that's a perfect place to stop
there's a bunch more things i would like
to talk to you about but you know we've
we we traversed a lot of ground and you
can have me back any time you know good
thank goodness
you thanked me for coming on but i'm
pretty sure i was like can i come on to
your podcast jordan
that's actually what happened so i
appreciate it i'm i'm really pleased to
have you on it i i really appreciate it
talking to you and there are other
things i'd like to talk to you about in
the future i didn't talk to you about
you know potential political ambitions
and many other things but that's this
was good so
and that ended well so
look thanks a lot eh and uh i really
appreciate it yeah and thanks for your
service
you know well thank you
thank you yeah really
i know as academics we're protected by a
ring of people who put themselves on the
line to make sure we have the freedom to
complain
well you know i uh
i never really saw the seal teams of
service because it was it was this
adventure for us um
uh if you look at if you know matt best
he was actually they're part of black
rifle coffee familiar with them he wrote
a book called thank you for my service
and i think that actually gets really to
the how a lot of veterans feel about
their service they're like i got to go
jump out of airplanes and go
you know blow things up with my best
friends i don't understand how this is
surface this is great and yeah sometimes
you lose an eye but you signed up for it
um i will say politics feels a lot more
like service but i will say that
that's
because it's there's zero glory in it uh
but it's important and you know that's
that's it's fulfilling that's why i do
it
hey man thanks a lot and for the
invitation to the youth summit
yeah hey we're gonna keep uh when we get
dates for next year we're going to keep
bugging you about it so
love to would love to see you there
hopefully how's your health are you
feeling better
yeah
i'm still like running about 70 but
that's better than two
that's a hell of a lot better than two
yeah it is yes
so thank you for using a lot a lot more
than most people
um
well we need you the world needs you
please please take care of yourself good
good good luck with your political
duties and hopefully we'll talk soon
all right yeah i need it
thanks jordan
[Music]
you